FOR THE DELAY WE- WHEN FOR A
NUMBER OF FOLKS TO ARRIVE BUT
WANTED TO WE'RE GONNA START IS
SUBCOMMITTEE. I'LL GET A FEW OF
THE- THE LOGISTICS OF THE WAY-
DUE TO THE CONTINUED SAID HOME
WATER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THEY'RE AT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRED THAT MASSIE
WARNED AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE
AND BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM WHERE THEVIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU NOT
HAVE A MASK TO PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. WE ALSO A DIFFERENT A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS A WITNESS
TESTIFIED TODAY- TODAY IN FORTY
TWO A TWO WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE MINIMAL CONTENTION
OF STAFF LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
CHECK MAINTAIN SIXTY OF SPACING
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT FISCAL
DISCIPLINE PROPOSED FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. IN FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM IF ANY OF THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM LIKE A TEST FIVE PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND WILL I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH A
MICROPHONE AT THE PROPER TIME
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC THAT TAKES
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIST
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
HERE ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO THEIR
PHYSICAL DISMISSING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR. USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR THOSE OF
THE REMOTE. REMOTE TEST SITES.
WE HAVE SO BUILDINGS IS THAT
WANT TO USE THOSE THE ROOM
WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS IN OTHER
LOCATIONS AS WELL THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES- WILL BE USING AN
AUTOMATED TELEPHONE SERVICE-
WHICH ANYONE IS GOING O FIND A
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREENS IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION WE
HAVE ONE BILL TODAY- THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACING QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. THE COSBY ADVISE
THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
THE BILL YOUR MAY I LIVE LINE
AND YOU WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS OF THE MODERATED-PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE HAD 916-319-2093 AND
TRANSPORTATION STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO ASSIST I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THAT THEY WILL BE WE WILL
BE ACCEPTING OF IN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITIONAL LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- AND
YOU CAN PROVIDE- TO SOMEBODY
THERE THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC. HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. ONE IS THE AVERAGE QUORUM
QUICK AS A AS WE BEGIN. FONG
HERE. RENDON. BOB HERE.
ARAMBULA. SOURCE AND PROTECT.
FONG HERE. MY PHONE. FOUR TIMES
THE TRUCK AND THEN. AT THAT
MOMENT REALLY SURE. THANK YOU.
HOW MY FOR MY BOSS. FOR THE
PLAN FOUR HERE FOR THE FOR TIME.
HERE ARAMBULA HERE BERMAN HERE
TO. HERE CUNNINGHAM. FRIEDMAN
HERE GIPSON YEAH HERE MASON.
HERE KILEY YEAH HERE MEDINA
HERE HERE DONNELL. THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK MR
ABDULLAH AND HIS RIVAS AND
MISTER RIVAS FOR SUBBING TODAY-
ON OUR COMMITTEE WITHOUT
FURTHER DO WE WILL HEAR SB FOUR
SEVEN NINE AS A MEMBER GLORIA.
I BELIEVE IS HERE TO TESTIFY.
IT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M
HERE TODAY- MEMBERS TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY NINE BY
HALF OF THE SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
TO RELINQUISH THIS PORTION OF
THE STATE ROUTE SEVENTY FIVE IN
THE ENTIRETY OF STATE ROUTE TWO
EIGHTY TWO IN THE CITY OF
CORONADO. MINISTER WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
A MODERATOR- WE CAN LET THE
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. I LIKE BE
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU BYE SHARE
FONG ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RICHARD BAILEY NOT HAVE
THE HONOR OF SERVING AS THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OR HOW ABOUT
THE PORT OUT OF IT WE'VE TO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL FOUR SEVEN
NINE TO ACCOMPLISH DAY ROUTE
SEVENTY FIVE IN TWO EIGHTY TWO
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF CORONADO.
ON JUNE SIXTEENTH OF THIS YEAR
CITY COUNCIL CORNARO
UNANIMOUSLY DIRECTED THAT ALL
ACTION NECESSARY TO EFFECTUATE
THE RELINQUISHMENT AND
ACCEPTANCE OF THESE ROADWAYS
PUBLISHED. OR NOT HAS BEEN
ENGAGE WITH CALTRAIN IN
INFORMAL DISCUSSIONS WITH
REGARD TO RELINQUISHMENT FOR
OVER A DECADE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
RELINQUISHMENT ASSESSMENT.
REPORTS WERE COMPLETED BY
CALTRANS. TO IF THE REAL. OF
STATE ROUTE SEVENTY FIVE IN TWO
EIGHTY TWO. OR CORPORATE FROM
THE DAY TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
PERSPECTIVE AND NEEDS REPORT
CONCLUDED IT WASN'T BACK-APPROPRIATE. AFRICAN AFTER
CONDUCTING MULTIPLE. AND DATE
OF OWN THE CITY CORNER
DETERMINE IT WOULD ALSO IN THE
EAST INTEREST TO TAKE OWNERSHIP
OF STATE ROUTE TWENTY FIVE. TWO
ADD OWNERSHIP WILL PROVIDE FOR
GREATER LOCAL CONTROL THE
ROADWAYS AND SO DID A RIGHT OF
WAYS WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
STATE LAW. THE PEOPLE NOT
APPRECIATE OUR WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CALTRANS
EMPLOYEES RELINQUISHMENT OF
STATE ROUTE SEVENTY FIVE IN TWO
EIGHTY TWO. IT MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL FOR BOTH THE STATE
AND CITY WE THANK CENTER LEADER
ATKINS AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND RESPECTFULLY.
ASK THE COMMITTEE APPROVAL
THANK YOU. I THINK VERY MUCH AT
THE NEXT. ONE IS THERE NEXT
WITH HIS. GOOD MORNING SURE%
ENOUGH COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS A CALL FOR OUR I AM DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC SERVICES VETERINARIAN
FOR THE CITY OF CORONADO AND I
DO NOT HAVE A STATEMENT I AM
JUST AVAILABLE PERCENT
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TO BE
ANSWERED ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CORONADO. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE'LL START WITH- ANY
SPEAKERS OR ANY ANY INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN PERSON THAT WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NOBODY SHOULD- AND
THEY'RE IN THE ROOM HERE AT THE
ROCK WE'RE NOT TEST MY SITE WE
HAVE ANYONE THE REMOTEST MY
SIDE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
FAVOR. OF THIS BILL SB FOUR
SEVEN NINE. SEEING NONE. I'M AS
MODERATOR WE HAVE ANY%
INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE THAT
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF- OF
THIS BILL AS WE WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR- THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR FOR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
GOING UP AT THIS TIME OF THE
DAY CARE. I THANK YOU MODERATOR
ANYONE IS GETTING ONE. WE ARE
JUST GETTING ONE ONE MOMENT.
OKAY THE OPERATORS GIVEN THE
LINE NUMBER ONE SECOND PLEASE
NO WORRIES PLEASE RECEIVE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. AND LIVE
FOURTEEN YOU ARE NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GARETH
SMYTH WITH THE NAVY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU DR THE
SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE MITIGATION LANGUAGE TO
SAFEGUARD OPERATIONS ON THE
FACILITY THANK YOU. NOBODY ELSE
IS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. I
THANK YOU MODERATOR- ARE THERE
ANY ANY INDIVIDUALS LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN PERSON I DON'T. SEE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT HAS.
AND WILL HAS RISEN-
ADVERTISEMENT THAT IS THERE
ANYONE IN A REMOTE TEST MY SITE
LIKE THIS BEGIN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE MISTER MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB. SIX FOUR SEVEN NINE. PLEASE
UP PRESS ONE ZERO IT TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ONE ZERO PLEASE. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. I THINK THIS OF
POEMS MODERATOR- TAKING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I WAS A GUY WITH A
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU HAVE
A- I THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND AYE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOUR SEVEN NINE MOTION IS TO
PASS. FONG HI FONG HI. ARAMBULA
ARRAY HI. BERMAN BERMAN HI CHIU.
CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI KILEY. KILEY
HI MEDINA MEDINA HI O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HI. FOURTEEN NICE
FOURTEEN EYES WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR AT FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY TWELVE EYES
ON HOLIDAYS MY BODY'S TWELVE
EYES AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR- THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU. THINK WAS CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SIR. ACTUALLY WALKING
IN ANY MINUTE. THE TOPIC THAT.
YEAH DEFINITELY SICKENING GOING.
THANK YOU SIR. CUNNINGHAM HI.
ALL RIGHT THAT WILL BE.
THIRTEEN ALL RIGHT THAT BILL
GETS OUT AND THAT WILL
CONCLUDE- THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOW TURNED.